on marchait de notre dame à versailles
ce dimanche les discussions habituelles
ont laissé place aux interrogations
d'entre deux tours alors que dans les
yvelines les deux vainqueurs du premier
tour de la présidentielle sont emmanuel
macron et jean luc mélenchon à
versailles eric zemmour se classe
deuxième avec plus de 18 % des voix ces
dix points au dessus de la moyenne
nationale
il est intelligent courageux et qu' il
avait
une contribution qui paraissait très
positive à la campagne il ya eu un bon
travail de terrain et les équipes séjour
avec bonne implantation dans versailles
les avis des habitants semble contraster
une ville traditionnellement de droite
alors bon
macron ne satisfaisait peut-être pas la
majorité des gens ils sont allés un peu
vers les extrêmes était une ville où je
pense qu'il ya pas forcément de problème
mais il ya quand même une typologie de
gens qui sont craintifs qui ont peur
d'eux qui ont des idées un peu
particulières c'est bien connu ça et
bien que les français ne votent pas pour
ils votent contre donc il ya des gens
qui détestent monsieur macron à cause de
sa politique sociétale zemmour appel à
des valeurs d'antan de lui un côté un
peu traditionalistes et réac les
versailles et se tournent maintenant
vers l'avenir mais une chose est sûre à
une semaine du second tour le résultat
n'est pas joué d'avancé
je vais voter macron parce que c'est
moins pire des deux c'est contre macron
plus que pour le pen en fait c'est le
moment de changer de voir ailleurs si
c'est possible macron il n'a rien fait
pendant cinq ans donc on espère
un changement tout simplement j'irai
peut-être voter macron mai vraiment sans
conviction il faut chasser macron et
nous appelons à voter pour marine le pen
une pension que mâcon représente un
danger pour les libertés en france et
qu'il a fait preuve d' incompétent un
certain nombre de domaines un
face-à-face identique aux élections
présidentielles de 2017 mais qui
pourrait cette fois-ci s'avérer plus
serrée entre les deux candidats réponse
le 24 avril prochain